[Music]
hasta is a very popular character in a
world with insanely likable characters
like shown and protagonist graduate Yami
best girl Noel and best firebender foo
go Leone Austin managed to get more love
than all of them in the Japanese
popularity polls
Austin got first in both in the English
polls Yami actually came in first
but hasta was still near the top at
second place so the question is why is
Austin so popular
what is his appeal and how can we
improve our own lives by learning from
his example this is the first time I'm
doing this kind of video and ideally as
well as dissecting a character's appeal
I'd like to also talk about how you and
I could improve our own lives by
learning from the exemplary character in
question some people might say that it's
just Anna Mae don't overthink it but my
brother Anna Mac and I would testify any
day to Anna Mae's ability to improve
one's life kameena and the ideal he
represents has literally inspired us and
shaped our lives more than many IRL
people there's nothing wrong with
watching anime for pure escapism but I
personally feel that the ideal is
enjoying the anime but also learning
from it and using that knowledge to
improve your own life for me watching
Naruto Luffy or hasta chase their dreams
is not enough I use their stories as
motivation to chase my own dreams one of
which was to be a full-time youtuber and
I managed to accomplish that in part two
the lessons I learned and motivation I
got from anime so that is where the idea
for this video series comes from from a
desire to illustrate how in drawing
anime can actually help you crush it in
your real life feel free to suggest
characters that inspired you in the
comment and I can make a similar video
about them in the future now let's
return to Austin and his appeal also
start from the bottom to say he is an
underdog is an understatement in a world
where magic and nobility are said to be
the most important things also starts
out as a magic list and poor orphan
Austin could have dealt with the
situation in many different ways
he could have cursed his fate that he
was born magic less and spent the rest
of his days complaining about how unfair
life is he could have decided that a
poor kid with no magic could never be a
magic night and devote himself to some
other profession but he didn't do that
either
instead also despite his background
decided that he was going to be the
wizard King a title that is supposed to
go to the strongest mage of the clover
kingdom his magic wasn't showing up so
instead of complaining about how you
know already had awesome magic powers
also spent his time improving on things
he could improve like his physical
strength he trained so hard that he
actually became the second strongest
character in all of black clover that we
met so far he has only yet to catch up
to Yami hasta is an optimist through and
through he always looks at the bright
side and trust that if he continues to
work hard he will be able to achieve his
dreams even after he doesn't receive a
grimoire initially he doesn't give up
and he has patient he says after he
doesn't get a grimoire initially that
even if it takes a year or two he will
get a grimoire now people might say that
Aastha got lucky since he happened to
get chosen by the five leaf clover
grimoire when he was fighting red chief
if it wasn't that stroke of luck then he
would have just been completely
destroyed by referee and his dream of
becoming the wizard king would have
ended there however there's a quote
attributed to Coleman Cox that goes I'm
a great believer in luck the harder I
work the more of it I seem to have often
in real life two people will say that
successful people got a lucky break but
the truth is before you can be lucky you
have to not give up work hard and be
ready to take advantage of an
opportunity when it shows itself austell
is almost ready to give up like many of
us experience doubt in our own lives
this proves that hasta experiences the
same doubts we all do but still keeps
moving towards his goals thanks to his
own willpower and you know calling him a
rival Austin decides that he won't give
up this was an opportunity where Austin
might have given up and he never might
have received his grimoire and anti
magical powers this reminds me of this
image right here where you see a man
turning back and giving up just before
he was gonna get to his goal that could
have been Austin but Austin kept going
and that's why he was rewarded with a
grimoire and his newfound power in Paulo
Coelho is the alchemist there's a
powerful quote that goes like this
when you want something all the universe
conspires in helping you to achieve it
this is how I view Aust the story he has
a goal he works hard towards it and he
refuses to give up so it makes sense
that the universe would eventually
reward him for his efforts
once again later on also has another
perfect reason to give up on his dreams
when he is told by the wizard King's
doctor the person who should know better
than anyone else that his cursed arms
will never go back to normal
Yami even says that if the clover
kingdoms top recovery mage says so that
it's the truth
most people would accept what the doctor
said not hasta though he is told that he
will never swing a sword again and he
uses that to get himself fired up he
says that he will find a way to heal
these arms or that he'll find some other
strength besides his arms and use that
to fight all the way to the end during
this part and the part in the following
chapter we're asked over here is Noel
talking about how the black bulls are
trying to help him and he breaks out
into tears because he realizes that he
was blessed with great friends I
couldn't help but cry myself how can you
not love this guy someone who knows what
he wants refuses to give up values the
people around him and is in general such
a positive guy he is the opposite of
spoiled he always focuses on the
positive he could complain because the
hardships he's had to face in life but
instead he has immense gratitude for
what he does have one of my favorite
moments in the manga is actually a small
moment but I think it beautifully
captures y hasta is so likable magma is
showing hasta to his room he shows him
into a to use his words tiny dirty and
sad room that is twice as small as his
own room and he thinks Austin's gonna be
disappointed but also absolutely beaming
he is deeply moved to the point of Tears
he cannot believe that he gets his very
own room he takes great pride in having
his very own room for the first time and
starts cleaning it immediately it's a
small and quick moment but it
illustrates one of my favorite things
about Austin his positivity his
gratitude we can't help but root for an
underdog like him who finds too good in
situations that would upset or even
devastate other people he inspires us to
be better people just as he inspires
almost
every character he meets in the manga
from you know - magma - Noel and so on
his positivity is contagious
ostrich Allen jizz us to work hard
employ patience and persistence and see
the good in our own lives Austin's not
some special person who is cut from a
different cloth for instance Naruto and
Luffy are special Naruto's father was an
exceptionally talented Hokage and his
mother was a strong and talented ninja
in her own right furthermore he had the
nine tailed beasts sealed inside him
from his childhood although Naruto also
tells itself as if it's an underdog
story
Naruto comes off as a special chosen one
who was destined to be great Luffy also
had a powerful father and grandfather
then there's also the D in monkey D
Luffy the will of D makes it seem like
he too is destined to be great
not to mention that Luffy starts out as
a talented and confident fighter with
special powers we do not see as much as
that initial doubt that we see when
Austin almost gives up against rep Chi
or even the doubt and sadness Naruto
experiences in the beginning in that
sense Luffy seems less relatable in the
beginning although we definitely see
chinks in the armor later on in the
series austat least so far does not seem
to have the same chosen one he is fated
to be great vibe about him
we do not know about any skilled parents
whose genes would foreshadow his
greatness in fact he does not seem
special except in the sense that he has
no magic in a world filled with magic
users the witch queen makes this clear
at one point she says and I quote I
assume you were one of their kin but I
was wrong you're simply defective a
sudden mutation kept mana from dwelling
in you
however because of that you were able to
wield that sword you weren't special or
anything like that but that is what
makes you special
in fact while Luffy and Naruto seemed
fated to be great a lot of black clover
seems to be overcoming faith like when
hasta says messing with me again faith
when he loses the ability to use his
arms or when Yami says yeah good old
faith I hate that stuff who'd listen to
it anyway even if I have to crush fate
I'll do whatever I want
black clover at least so far seems to be
about creating your own destiny no
matter who you are or where you come
from which is definitely a message I can
get behind that is what hasta would
succeed improving if he were to work his
way up from a poor magic 'less orphan to
the position of wizard king this is why
I want Austin to be the wizard king over
you know because you know was born with
insane magical talent making Austin much
more of an underdog Austin never gave up
even after years of training and that
training bearing little fruit
nonetheless he kept going and eventually
the universe did reward his perseverance
with the five leaf clover grimoire which
actually turned his weakness his
inability to use magic into a strength
he couldn't use magic and instead of
focusing on what he couldn't do he
focused on what he could improve namely
his physical strength because he worked
so hard on it
he was eventually able to wield the
heavy anti magic swords that came out of
his five leaf clover grimoire hasta is
relatable he starts out with the cards
stacked against him and he experiences
doubt but he transcends his limitations
through hard work persistence positivity
and gratitude as a result he inspires
others whether in the series or in real
life to be better people and that is the
appeal of Austin Austin journey in many
ways reflects my own when I was a kid my
family moved to Canada because of the
war in the former Yugoslavia my family
and I didn't speak English and in
regards to wealth we had to leave the
little that we did have behind and start
over in a completely foreign country
understandably English was my worst
subject for a while and in grade 9 my
English teacher even told me to move
down to applied English which would mean
that I'd be moved to an easier English
class and that I'd pretty much lose any
chance of going to university however I
was always sure that I was gonna go to
university it was never even a question
for me suddenly a 13 year old me was
being told it wasn't gonna happen and I
had a choice to make just like Austin
did when people said that he was
talentless or when the doctor said that
he couldn't be a magic knight anymore I
could believe the teacher and moved out
to applied English giving up any hopes
of going to university or I could prove
her
and I decided to prove her wrong I
decided to stay in academic English and
I worked hard even though you could say
that English was my second language and
I had no talent for it I ended up
finishing off the class with an 80% a
mark higher than most of the native
English speakers got in that class I
kept working hard and my English marks
kept improving partly thanks to my older
brother Anna Mac the other half of anime
uproar I started to enjoy reading he
challenged me to read the katha
Montecristo which was a giant book for
me at the time and once again
I rose to the occasion although it was a
long book I loved it and I began reading
more and more books for fun in my last
year of high school I got the highest
mark in my English class I went on to
major in the English language and
literature in university and then I even
got a master's degree in get this
English since that day I decided to
prove that grade 9 teacher wrong I never
got a final mark below an A in high
school or university and I went on to
win many academic awards like Austen
even if I started behind everyone else I
refused to give up and worked hard and
in doing so I killed my limits as Yami
would say my story of becoming a
youtuber was very similar my brother and
I were told that we couldn't do it many
times but we worked hard and managed to
make that dream a reality - like hasta
you're gonna face challenges in life
people are gonna try to tell you what
you can't do they're gonna try to impose
limits on you you can either accept
those limits or blast through them and
find a way to succeed be grateful be
positive be persistent and work hard and
there's no dream you can't turn into
reality so this video was a bit more
personal near the end than my other
videos but I really wanted you guys to
know that anime like black clover are
not pure fiction in the sense that many
times they reflect real universal
principles that can and should be
applied to real life anyways thank you
so much for watching it's the first time
I've done a video like this where I
incorporated more self development in
personal details so let me know how you
like this style of video by hitting that
like button or letting me know in the
comments like I said let me know if
there are any
they're characters you'd like to see
dissected in the future if you want more
hit that subscribe button notification
Bell to stay up to date with new videos
take what I said in this video and apply
it to your real life go out there and
kill your limits and until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]